it's a nice room on my name is Frances
guy I'm director-general of the world
intellectual property organization which
is an international intellectual
international intergovernmental
organization based in Geneva in
Switzerland I'm going to address the
question of come out reviews from
facebook please tell us what you care
about what future direction was said and
how you contribute to encouraging the
state of the world so what I'd like to
say here is how to participate in some
very interesting conversations about the
direction of science and technology we
all know this is moving at a rapid pace
we are one of the difficulties we have
these have now social and legal
institutions accommodate this change and
keep pace with it there are lots of is
Northwestern's richer of fundamental
importance such as information about
your human genome what people might know
about that we can be used cannot be used
what are your rights have control over
these many ethical question is in all
areas of science so what I would like to
see actually is that science is main
string out and just as we talk about the
economic crisis that we learned how to
talk about some of these major circuit
advances and the social and political
implications that they throw up and to
democratize the debates in this way